I don't know how we came up with that
but that's that's your fault all of you
we'll get five suggestions then we'll
drop a beat and we'll do a wrap let's
come we'll start with this side of the
room hello what would you like to hear a
wrap about triathlons triathlons do you
do triathlons he does oh he does well
thank you very much for being so Noble
that you suggested it for him cuz he was
like oh I hope someone says triathlons
otherwise how will people know I do
triathlons you're wearing a backwards
baseball cap you
are insufferable okay triathlons which
bit of the triathlon do you find hardest
um running the running okay cool where
are you from I'm from Japan you're from
Japan cool so Japanese triathlons great
running running okay um let's uh let's
come to this section what do you guys
want to wrap about this
section yes sorry the the stoner section
of the thing this section
yes so far we've had Japanese triathlons
what's yours going to be give us
something about
German scientists German scientists
lovely stuff okay German scientists
middle of the room hello what would you
like a wrap about triangles sticks
triangles and mozzarella sticks what a
great combination mozzarella triangles
is what we're going to do this segment
suggestion number
four okay there were so many so one
second that's too British what did you
so what did what was from the back
abortion abortion aliens and you said
babies okay alien baby abortions I don't
know how we came up with that but that's
that's your fault all of you and then
the final suggestion will come from this
section gir giraffes I I mean I think I
said no food or animals but I feel I
feel like uh I'll really upset you are
they your favorite
animals is that is he on a special night
out and he's we've given him some paper
to color in he's like you'll do a song
about giraffes yeah please than
you that's fine I used to work with
autistic kids so
I'm covered I've done my time I've
helped enough of them that I can be mean
to one of
them so to recap we have German
scientists we have Japanese triathlons
we have mozzarella triangles we have
alien baby abortions for which I can
only apologize and we have giraffes this
then lovely people of the comedy seller
is a freestyle uh DJ do me a favor drop
that beat and do not worry it will not
be anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly to caringly bad as you
expected to be if you do not like it
it's entirely your fault because you
picked what the rap is about do not
blame me we'll start Sir with yours to
keep you happy keep you on the side keep
you from unleashing your inner anger and
sadness so let's do
this suggestion you save the best to
last politely ass guy from the back
shouting giraffes you see them in the
zoo you're like whoa look at that neck
how high does it go you got the yellow
on the skin the brown on the dots they
got a long gray tongue munching lots of
all the leaves and branches that's the
answer giraffe oh yes put it together
like a sandwich with cheese in the
middle bread crumbs on the side usually
a stick usually the size of this but you
were saying no I want to handle an extra
Corner make that [__] a triangle so I'm
the fella invent mozzarella add a few of
those sticks together now you got the
three equal lateral that's 60° angles
inside you all any type of scientist
would know the question is asks adds up
to 180 do the Mas but these guys over
there the corner purring they're like M
scientist German
ah no rehearsal I know scientists quite
controversial if they came here in the
late 40s those scientists did things
quite naughty if before of a time when
they came from that they were like no
please don't send us back we got to help
you with your weapons development in in
the room there's a massive elephant and
I'm not exciting the guy who loves
animals big gray wrinkles they can
handle oh this is really great I'm glad
that I could say in Jas cuz now he's
rapping about these Trunks and this hunk
over there a fly man where's he coming
from rising sun in Japan he be giving it
the heck he running and he's swimming he
Cycles so fast that you know that he's
winning and the women like hey this
guy's a gold medalist when it comes to
running yeah he struggles a little bit
he's like I really think I need to make
sure heal my shin splits and if you run
fast you win you're there on the podium
after the water bit Jesus Christ you're
Frozen got a wear a swimming suit and
then up on the bike there's nothing
funny about triathlons tonight I already
was mean about the German guy so I'm
moving on there quickly no surprise you
were looking up from below saying please
abduct Me and your UFO and while you're
up there set me straight I'll open wide
yeah [__] impregnate me I go there
head like crazy look at this swollen
alien baby and then you go back down to
earth you're like [__] I should have
thought before I [__] first where are
you walking check first you can't get
abortions of any kind in Texas or
anywhere in the South move quickly head
on up to New York from Mississippi
Tennessee Louisiana you should have
thought before you got abducted you
should have really planned when they
take you from the planet Earth you
should have packed in your pants and
plan be first and that way you could
have taken the pill but no you've got an
alien baby and now you're going to kill
[Music]
him
goodby